I was here I've only seen this doll for
five minutes and I'm already believing
nope
today we're going to be talking about
the movie Annabelle and it's soon to be
really sequel Annabelle creation
what doll the waitress I guess it's a
prequel I don't know
definitely a prequel Annabelle is a
spin-off to the conjuring series haunted
dolls are a staple for cinema from
Chucky to that clown doll and
poltergeist that I don't really want to
talk about and Annabelle is the latest
addition to this terrifying lineup of
spooky places today's episode if you
haven't guessed we're going to live with
haunted dolls for this challenge nyla
and I will buy allegedly haunted dolls
from the weird part of the internet live
with those dolls for 24 hours and if our
bodies and soul survive we'll return
here to determine whether the experience
of living with a haunted doll was fresh
just plain rotten so you actually
believe in haunted dolls I believe in
energy
I plan on trying to make this doll as
haunted as possible you need Jesus I'm
gonna name my doll Annabelle creation
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should get me a black or brown woman
doll
not this one with missing eyes no when
it comes to the supernatural I'm more
cautious than scared about it the
problem is a lot of these dolls are
especially pale give me a creepy little
white girl why not
this one 75% often looks kind of racist
the worst thing that could possibly
happen is kind of feeling like there's a
presence always with me afterwards so
this one's name is Emily Emily was a
very important and well-loved
schoolteacher she devoted her life to
helping children in bad neighborhoods
Emily's spirit is very active she loves
to talk and helps children you should
get that one for yours I'm getting this
doll for you
I'm a pretty rational person I'm pretty
logical I want you to find me the most
haunted worst story doll really demented
messed up okay
just nothing sticky why would you
possess a doll if I could possess
something I possess like a Space Shuttle
like a paranormal metaphysical EVP
porcelain spirit doll this sounds pretty
promising her name is Anastasia she lost
her life during the tragic volcanic
eruption do you think they asked her
that did you die in a volcano yes I
would love to be murdered by a doll I
kind of like her she seems cool okay I
[Music]
was feeling a little uneasy so I decided
to talk to Ryan Vergara who is our
resident ghost hunter here and he had
actually gone to an island full of
haunted dolls my goal is to say safe how
do I do that if I were you I would just
hunker down leave it in any little area
do not communicate it don't touch it I
was thinking of like she just needs a
friends and so I'm like maybe I was
hoping that he would give me a little
bit of advice and a little bit of hope
if a spirit is trapped in something I
can't imagine a lot of good reasons for
that if it's a demonic presence it could
be a become a parasite in her life they
could ruin your life literally you could
kill you even if some glad I'm not doing
this in you are there is a lot of nights
I wake up screaming when I woke up
Brian Bergara is useless we finally got
the dolls in the mail wake up okay wake
up everybody it was kind of like the
opposite of opening your presents for
Christmas it's adorable oh hello ma'am
she's pretty Wow look at this dress
you're gonna live your life I'm gonna
live my life and she dead your name is
no longer Anastasia your name is
Annabelle creation all right let's get
this little Sam oh [ __ ]
ow oh my God look at this dolls already
fighting back there's just this metal
like staple that or something that's
like I've only seen this doll for five
minutes and I'm already bleeding you're
re taunting it and then you get stabbed
I'm stoked all right it's [ __ ] on I
just get this day done and over with
guys this young lady used to be named
Anastasia my desk mates really did not
take to Annabelle creation where are you
going two of them basically fled Becca
do many AI strategies how to get her to
haunt me they sort of wished that that
doll would teach me a lesson and make me
a little less insufferable haunt me so
far all you've done is stabbed me once
nyla how are you feeling I'm fine
where's your daughter she's living her
life and I'm living my life so far it's
been going pretty well
I mean she's looking at me I'm not
looking at her I think this establishes
a relationship of dominance for me so
she knows who's in charge Garrett has
been doing the complete opposite of what
I've been doing he's been carrying his
doll by the hair is your name
Annabelle creation this is pretty dumb I
think we're both two sort of pushing it
off yeah I'm gonna possess this coin
with the oeg board we'll put the little
portal viewer on it and now this is a
haunted coin are you possessed by a
spirit
heads yes tails nose yes that's a yes
she really was very true to herself with
every question I asked are you going to
murder me
that's a heads so I'm glad now you is
Emily Nyla's doll going to murder nyla
that's a tails well nobody's going to
murder nyla can I ask a question yeah
please
are you going to murder me or anyone
that I low in love
that's a heads it sucks man as really
sex so the rest of the day I tried to
give her every advantage I could to make
her potential as a haunted objects I'm
through
[Music]
he's not like bark and I are scared or
anything these things it smells weird
because it's an old dumb dog
[Music]
come on
and untied one of her shoes as the day
came to an end I realized this doll and
I were just gonna be alone when I got
home best of luck Garrett sure you have
our dolls give up cuz you've been dogs
that all know I'm good there we go
alright I just got home from work
thinking about what I want to eat for
dinner and also remembering that I need
to take this young lady with me wherever
I go
the doll is in my bag but before that
was weird
Oh might have been a sage piece okay I'm
freaking myself out got it show I really
just saged every single door away the
inside of my closet which is probably a
fire hazard but it's okay
nyla Lisa does not play I even saved my
cat he was not feeling it come here
honey
let me just save you there we go I'm
taking a dark way home if she was
looking for an opportunity she'll find
one for most the rest of the evening it
was very easy to ignore Annabelle I made
sure she was staring at me the whole
night she was right next to me while I
was doing a crossword puzzle I didn't
even notice do something it's time for
bed the doll is over there she's gonna
sleep right there we'll see what happens
good night Annabelle creation good night
[Music]
it's morning the doll is still where I
left it I woke up this morning happy to
still be alive I was happy to not be
possessed woke up an hour before my
alarm completely refreshed the one odd
thing was that Annabelle was no longer
beside me
[Music]
quick scan of the room and I saw that
she had just fallen off the bed like a
stupid extra pillow overall I found the
experience of living with a haunted doll
a bit disappointing I was pretty bored I
was never murdered and actually carrying
around this cursed doll became kind of a
burden all that considered I have no
choice but to call it the experience
living with a haunted doll was
unpleasant it really validated that I
loved living alone and I ignored it and
I will continue to ignore it for those
reasons I also rate the experience as I
think I want to resell my doll and let
somebody else enjoy it they should be
friends oh yeah we should sell this like
a package deal to haunted dolls ones a
very very naughty girl but one's a very
very good girl
[Music]